with all the talk about police brutality
in the US right now we wanted to answer
a seemingly simple question when is it
okay for police to shoot someone in the
US we're not talking on ethical grounds
we just wanted some straightforward
legal guidelines and as you may have
guessed they aren't as simple as you'd
hope the first thing to know is officers
are trained to use their guns as a last
resort but even then people always ask
why don't they just shoot in the arm or
leg cops are actually trained to aim
here rather than here or here
meaning they probably won't miss and the
suspect probably won't survive so what
is it actually okay for cops to kill
under US law there are two circumstances
the first is in defense of life whether
it's to protect their own life or the
life of another so if a suspect is
aiming a gun or what looks like a gun
directly at an officer then the officer
can legally shoot the suspect if he
believes his life is in danger
the second circumstance is to prevent a
suspect from escaping but only if the
cop has reason to think that the suspect
poses a significant violent threat to
the community
whatever that means this became law
thanks to the 1985 Tennessee vs. garner
Supreme Court case which concluded that
it was a Fourth Amendment violation for
police to fire at unarmed non violent
people running away in the case Edward
garner not to be confused with Eric
garner was shot dead by two police
officers after he fled the scene of a
house burglary the officers were trying
to stop Garner from climbing a fence to
get away when they killed him
$10 on a purse were found in Garner's
possession and he was 15 so there's got
to be a significant threat but according
to who the legal answer the officer
involved they have to have quote
objectively reasonable belief that there
was a threat even if there wasn't this
law comes from another Supreme Court
ruling 1989 s Graham versus Connor in
this case D thorn Graham was having a
diabetic attack went to buy an orange
juice from a convenience store but
quickly left when he saw the long line a
nearby officer suspected that Graham was
robbing the store when he saw his quick
exit sokeep slam
him against the hood of a police car
freakin grams foot the court ruled that
officers don't have to demonstrate
whether or not their intentions were
good but rather that their actions were
objectively reasonable given their
perception of what happened okay so
that's the law for everybody but police
departments policies vary some only
allow their officers to use lethal force
in the first circumstance or in defense
of life if they're cops fire at a
fleeing suspect they could lose their
jobs but they probably won't be charged
with a crime so for a cop to shoot his
gun he's got to have an objectively
reasonable belief that there is a
significant threat when you really think
about it there is no standard for
knowing when lethal force is needed it
really just depends on how the cop sees
it
you